welcome back to GameSpot's continuing
coverage of e3 2014 we are on the
gamespot stage here and I'm delighted to
be joined by the pride of the Costa
Rican game development community mr.
Eduardo Ramirez my friend how are you
doing I am fine how i do feat a pretty
good III has been III has been fun how
is III even for you there's a lot of
talking to strange people like me or no
no no oh yeah I know you get 33 so did
you get to play much yourself as well oh
yeah bits and bobs but you're here with
Phoenix rage a game that made I remember
it made a big splash at PAX East yeah we
got great feedback there were you
expecting that like no it was it with
these things we finally people were able
to played for themselves and kind of
just because there's one of those games
where people were talking to each other
about yeah yeah that the mouth to mouth
publicity I guess yeah it was it went
right yeah so you guys are coming out on
steam later this year right yeah at
fault and if I believe is a massacre is
the genre that people like to define to
this this like almost like cat Mario
style difficulty of platforming yeah
when iris tile well not that Myra styles
more like so it was just funny in Sonic
so yeah no I mean I have you ever played
cat Mario getting are you yeah it's like
really ultra difficult stupid levels of
difficult like almost like us almost
like a thousand likes that there are
like clouds that yeah you [ __ ]
disappear yeah yeah that's awesome but
Phoenix raid your kind of what it seemed
it tickles that little nerve that I have
that when I played super meat boy it's
not like super sort of yeah difficult
for really tight controls that's what I
like I know we're looking at it here
yeah so basically it's a sonic inspired
and it's kind of a super meat boy
inspired so that's like a mex within
with of those and we ended up working
one year and a half
on this you know putting everything I la
we like yeah and well that's it is a
little result absolutely and so what
tell us about like the variety in the
levels and the speed at which you you go
through the levels what how big are the
letters usually the fly through them
this quickly I well there are small
levels and there are a huge level so it
depends of yeah the world but what I can
say that we wanted that the players
start with the full power right yeah and
it's only dice and jump that's simple as
that and we we are focused on the level
design so they would change a lot they
are smaller and no huge level of that is
there a narrative running through it as
well this stuff seems to suggest so no
there's no narrative for North Texas
it's a image space story yeah so I
thought oh this is a boss battle type
situation we have that sell us fight hey
what's the level structure are we
talking about you do like four or five
mini levels and then give a boss an den
it's on tabs there are all right all
right so there are eight worlds there's
a secret one yeah and for each world is
about 50 person needs Rojas to any level
so yeah it's lots of syllables hui ru
catering for that community of people
that like really hard games because on
PC in the past couple years like with
the success of meat boy the success of
you know not to keep everything with
those guys but like The Binding of Isaac
and the idea of like 2d platformers that
are challenging that aren't just like
easy to get through is that one who is
that who you're trying to appeal for
till specifically yet it specifically
yeah I was it's just this game it was
based on a prototype and guru made in
Google Play yeah yeah and we receive so
many good feedback and people comparing
to super meat boy in as well so it was a
you know it's a really basic it's just a
cute moving around you know everywhere
so from the feedback we got that they
were like hardcore players yeah that's
why we decided to make something like
that something else
it's vinny trade yeah yeah and instead
the speed that the fact we finished each
level the timer comes up and the fact
that the timer is ticking away in the
top corner hotel yeah in speedrunning
and leaderboards it's not your kind of
your focus on yeah I have to do that
because we ask you may know we're at
three guys from Costa Rica making this
and I'm you know the programmer so yeah
it's Owen to me so I yeah I want to have
the the leaderboards yeah yeah there's
only two of you working on it there's an
artist guy me the programmer I game
designer and the musicians oh ok ok so
the game parse error Oh is you all the
apartments are there oh yeah everyone's
a manager yeah yeah I definitely is
there is there much of a see it must be
strange kind of coming over here is
there much of your guys are still based
in Costa Rica sales are ya weirdo sarika
so I used I've been assuming there's not
much of a game's development community
down its way to sunny from nice for
people to say there's a few guys to
making games but we're all in this
nested really there's no like the
biggest company has like gives you guys
but yeah yeah not that much of a it's
not in terms of an indie yeah a lot of
in this I like that so what's it like
then coming over here as packs and
coming over maybe less so free 3 but
like being surrounded by people who are
very similar to you as a designer for
the furlough for the first time so many
of them it was awesome because this is
like really like the first go story
again that it's going to next-gen so and
yet it's like a whole new experience it
came out very fast and you the game was
completely underground on the unrevealed
in GDC this year really yeah Wow find
everything that's not its februari of
this year yeah ads in March actually
omars are you right yeah yeah it was so
quickly the home everything is collided
so it's incredible to have pack size
that power where if you put summation
yeah and put the game in people's hands
and allow them to you know and if it's
good enough and let them judge it yeah
then I kind of do the market already
feedback
yeah we are the flappy bird marketing I
guess people were saying yeah this feels
a lot bigger than it was yeah yeah it's
complete fluke yes that that happened at
that time as well we have made some more
details in the game then fly paper but
yeah that's ridiculous and so in terms
of them you said you keep saying the
feedback as well so yeah what was it
that happened at PAX that changed the
game playing phoenix wright the gameplay
well the gameplay the same we're just
well we're still working on finishing
the game they were yeah we're missing
you just won the world but um yeah it's
maybe some polish in with some level
said yeah the whole changes we made so
you guys are going to come out at q3
it's alright starting to fall in fall
this year for this for this year did
have a specific date yet you know no
still though and obviously it's coming
out on on steam is it going to have mac
or linux as well yeah it's see Johnny
snow melters teams getting up to
playstation 4 and xbox one yeah and i'm
guessing the leaderboard stuff is going
to be tied into steve i have to figure
that still working that i'm working that
i'm working out i guess because that's
outside of your environment at the
moment you're just with the game you're
building and so then in terms i guess
you know the obvious question at this
stage is are you eyeing up any consoles
your yacht III here you know Adam Boyes
is walking around the halls this
Microsoft guys are around like I are you
trying to see if you can get this
released on a console as well at some
stage as it goes on like a playstation 4
is double play what is as well yeah i
take it by sorry it's on playstation 4
xbox one and see everything yeah when
did you get those wrapped up when did
you when did you have ps4 and xbox one
since the GDC yeah whoa yet from GDC
everything is quoted i got all the
support from the sony guys and the
Microsoft guys own business moves fast
in games development yeah I yeah I have
to move faster to know I have to finish
the game and so how long have you been
working on phoenix rising we started
first of January 2013 and one year in a
five months six months yeah and was this
did you expect to have an I by this
stage yeah
yeah we decided that we got this award
in 2012 from sporanox they was huge in
that America yeah and that was our
motivation to make something even be
here and this is like the first project
we took like more than a year to Megan
yeah it was a huge decision but yeah
it's turning out pretty well and a lot
of questions coming in from the child
actually here I better get to I've been
ignoring them the whole time I feel
pretty bad about it and XOR asks how
many levels are in Phoenix rage how big
is it we have 200 but possibly we will
make available a little bit more yeah so
I'm once the game is released and do you
think you're gonna be creating more
level packs free or DLC ah well I can't
confirm that yet but I have so many
ideas since then so maybe we will make
more stuff as a DLC but we have to look
out for that I guess as a small team if
you're deciding to work on any game it's
going to take a lot of your time
especially if you're currently you're
the only actual designer and programmer
on it so if you make this game and then
decide to do DLC then I guess you're
stopping yourself from making a
completely new game which I imagine is
someone who's creative you might want to
do it's possible yes but uh it's a
challenge I don't have to it's my
challenge so why not a good situation to
be in so it's a good situation yes good
people are playing your game any what
you want to yeah defo provide more
levels for the mayor and were you
shocked by the reception that packs like
I'm obviously the sonic did the whole
convention got down on their knees and
prayed to Phoenix rage but worth when
you went there was your goal to drum up
support and and talk about Phoenix rage
or what was your goal just to to attend
and then meet people and well our
publisher reverb is helping you know
doing all that stuff but the reactions
like they were great they were great
they were people screaming at this
screen yeah it was awesome actually and
how does it feel like then too I
it doesn't change developments when
suddenly people have expectations about
your game like maybe maybe some people
want this to be a casual experience
maybe some people want this to be really
difficult but you as a designer yeah
when you hear that does it change the
way you feel about yes I just stick to
do to them the prototype idea so if I
will stick to the same hardcore gamer
thing oh yeah so you always have like a
sort of a focus on who you wanted
excellent some people are saying this is
so difficult but eventually they will
pass a level so yeah it's it's it's a
forward for hardcore gamers that's what
I yeah and Joe is this is this the
Eduardo is this the first III you've
actually been to yeah yourself what's it
like stepping into because I'm from
Ireland I'm from a small country that
this like that stuff doesn't happen and
you're from Costa Rica it's probably
where they don't have that yeah but yeah
so what's it like being here and then
seeing this side of the games industry
it is raised you that's the best
description it's right it's really huge
it being bigger than that then what I
expected yeah yeah is there any games
you want to see while you're here or are
you mostly shopping III will look for
them yeah eventually when I have time
because I you know I have to be the room
if this comet talk to people like me
about your video game yeah I apologize
and so lastly for everyone at home and
when it's Phoenix rage I have more
platforms when I when it's Phoenix rage
available a lot more consoles just find
one at consoles well or my goal is to
have it done fall 2014 ps4 ps4 xbox one
and steam also be so I don't thank you
very much for coming on strike you very
appreciate it and that's the look what
you launched get a good game a cookie I
didn't mention that the game is all
about cookies thank you so much I got a
cookie well this cookie get me high yeah
it's a Mike can you not confirm that
yeah it is the greatest III press kiss
ever yeah is it I didn't mention that in
the game there's a cookie for every
level all right and if you get an X
amount of level of cookies you can
unlock a cookie recipe and I also see
that the great website game spotting is
as comfortable
it's why no pleasure to meet you thank
you again for coming on a best of luck
would launch a Phoenix rage later this
year awesome